c'est le retour dont va plus loin cette
rentrée pas encore septembre on est à la
fin du mois d'août et on est ravi d'être
avec vous elle n'y va bon jour en jour
revivre venir evs est ravie de vous
avoir reporter de guerre indépendante
votre dernier voyage c'était en ukraine
juste avant l'été pour le magazine le
point et on va en parler d'ukraine dans
un instant avec nous également bâtisse
falvo rédacteur en chef ici même à
france24 bonjour baptiste que va trouver
là en ukraine l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique dont une mission
d'inspecteurs est en route pour apport
est déjà la centrale nucléaire la plus
grande d'europe fait crainte de
possibles fuites radioactives face au
combat que mène dans la région russe et
ukrainien écoutez le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne justement au
daytona exagération des sans exagération
cette mission sera la plus difficile de
l'histoire de la ja étant donné les
activités de combat active menée par la
fédération de russie sur le terrain nous
attendons de la mission une déclaration
claire des faits de violation de tous
les protocoles de sécurité nucléaire
open xml
pour témoigner de l'importance 1 de
cette mission c'est raphaël grossi lui
même le patron de l'iowa qui va sur le
terrain il fallait bien ça ni va même
avec les garanties données par vladimir
poutine à emmanuel macron téléphone la
semaine dernière ben on est en guerre
enfin c'est à dire nous avons deux
belligérants nous avons l'ukraine et la
russie qui s'accusent mutuellement de
frappe sur cette centrale donc il
fallait une tierce partie ça bien
entendu on ne peut croire finalement ni
les uns ni les autres mais moi ce que je
constate c'est que une fois de plus
l'application occidentale et onusiennes
internationale à très haut niveau
n'arrive que quand on a une grande peur
un grand danger parce que évidemment
tout ce qui touche une centrale
nucléaire la plus grande de l'europe etc
ça fait peur à tout le monde donc en
fait c'est comme vous vous souvenez en
plein milieu de l'été mi juillet
quand on a fini grâce à eau
à l'entremise de la turquie et d'autres
puissances à conclure à faire conclure
un accord pour le blé pour que les
bateaux repart de desa puisque l'ukraine
et la russie ensemble n'arrivait pas à
se mettre d'accord mais là c'est la même
chose on est dans le dans le même
processus pour redonner finalement de
l'intérêt que les occidentaux continuent
à s'intéresser à cette guerre du côté
des autorités ukrainiennes ont on
s'alarme un baptiste le risque
d'incendié est élevé assure l'opérateur
energoatom on distribue des pastilles
diodes aux habitants alors oui sur la
communication d'abord l'ukraine a tout
intérêt effectivement à maximiser la
menace le risque d'une fuite de
radioactivité pourquoi parce que c'est
meilleur moyen de sensibilité et de
sensibiliser la communauté
internationale par les deux fuites de
radioactivité s'est fait rentrer la
guerre directement dans le quotidien de
toute une population d'une population
européenne en ce qui concerne la réalité
du risque je ne peux que relayer les
paroles les experts en matière de
sécurité nucléaire donc si on les écoute
cette centrale a quand même été conçue
pour résister à un certain nombre de
chocs parle de catastrophe naturelle on
parle de chute d'un avion gros porteur
mais résister à des bombardements
notamment à certains types de
bombardement par exemple à des bombes ou
des missiles pénétrant là c'est une
autre crise qu l'ailé les réacteurs sont
entourés 1 par une enceinte de 300 le
béton d'un mètre le problème c'est
notamment la matière fissile radioactive
les déchets nucléaires la chine classée
ce sont des déchets propres encore une
fois je me fais le relais des experts si
ce sont des déchets qui n'ont pas encore
été utilisées donc pas irradiées le
risque est minime si ce sont des déchets
donc entreposés en dehors de l'enceinte
de confinement équipe eux sont des
déchets usagers il y à un risque déjà
plus substantielles enfin l'autre risque
pris très au sérieux c'est
l'interruption potentiel pendant
plusieurs heures de l'alimentation en
courant la centrale de zaporizhya s'il
n'ya pas le relais bien sûr de
générateurs au diesel et là ça peut
entraîner justement la panne du système
de refroidissement des réacteurs dans le
pire des cas une fusion du coeur du
réacteur c'est ce qui s'est passé à
fukushima donc pour répondre à la
question les past idiote je ne sais pas
lequel est fait maison mais le risque il
est réel et il a raison d'être pris en
compte moscou pourrait vraiment cherché
d'après voix n'a provoqué un incident en
une bombe sale au risque
d'exposer sa propre population non je ne
crois pas franchement ça je pense que ça
n'est pas possible on se souvient au
début de cette guerre des propos
belliqueux hyper agressive de vladimir
poutine sur le fait qu' il allait
éventuellement utiliser l'armé nucléaire
qui avait fait peur à tout le monde là
les propos sont plus les mêmes du côté
des russes et je dirais même qu'on a eu
une espèce quand même de concessions
sans doute stratégique de la part du
kremlin puisque au départ les russes
souhaitaient que la délégation
internationale passe non pas par le
territoire ukrainien pour arriver sur ce
territoire ukrainien contrôlé par les
russes de la centrale mais passe par le
côté russe or ce n'est pas ça qui va se
passer puisque les russes ont accepté et
c'est en train d'avoir lieu maintenant
aujourd'hui demain etc ils sont le
territoire ukrainien est vaste la
délégation internationale est en train
d'arriver par le territoire ukrainien
sous contrôle l'ukrainien et à un moment
donné évidemment cette délégation va
devoir changer de mains pas ses alliés
de fond de la ligne de front c'est à
dire voilà d'être sous contrôle et est
sous la sécurité des ukrainiens est
passé sous la sécurité russes donc que
ça va être très intéressant non
seulement ce qu'ils vont découvrir mais
ce qu'ils vont avoir à me raconter par
la suite non et c'est sans doute un ce
qui met le plus en péril finalement le
travail des inspecteurs le fait qu
ailleurs en ukraine on est loin très
loin d'une accalmie pour kiev la
reconquête du sud a même sonné revigoré
par les actes de résistance autour de la
crimée notamment les soldats ukrainien
ambitionne désormais de libérer kherson
la première ville un souvenez-vous
conquise par les russes écoutez ce qu'en
dit le président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky
l'ukraine reviendra c'est sûr ça motive
décembre c'est exactement ce que
symbolisera notre drapeau ukrainien
lorsque nous l'installeront à donetsk or
l'ivcc à marioupol dans toutes les
villes du dombass dans la région d'azov
dans toutes les régions sous occupation
russe dans l'oblast de kharkiv
zaporizhya carson et bien sûr en crimée
ce qu'on
bâtisse l'objectif c'est de repousser
l'armée russe de l'autre côté d'unia oui
on va peut-être d'ailleurs le voir sur
la carte que la position de la ville de
renson faut être très prudent sur ces
annonces quand même de l'armée de
l'armée ukrainienne depuis des mois on a
des contre offensives qui sont
régulièrement annoncés au final pour
l'instant celle quelques villages ont
été repris ces dernières semaines cette
fois la contre-offensive à l'air quand
même plus solide d'abord parce que ces
dernières semaines l'ue l'ukraine a
effectué un travail de sape en fait en
bombardant autour de renson on le voit
ici donc dans l'oblast de renson des
entrepôts de munitions et surtout des
ponts qui permettent de traverser le
nieppe faut savoir que la russie a
établi ses troupes des deux côtés du
nieppe cela rives est et sur la rive
ouest au nord et au sud entre guillemets
est en fait en frappant les ponts
l'ukraine aurait réussi à 40 quasiment
isolée finalement les troupes russes qui
se trouve au nord donc du fleuve dniepr
ça permettrait donc de faciliter cette
reprise de territoire et c'est peut-être
pas un hasard d'ailleurs si l'offensive
a visiblement commencez donc par cette
rive ouest du fleuve dniepr voilà donc
maintenant quand même une très très
grande prudence et rappelons que l'armée
ukrainienne a eu des succès jusqu'ici en
termes défensif reconquérir massivement
des territoires là c'est une autre
épreuve qui l'attend objectifs
stratégiques ou symboliques and armée
creden a les moyens de ses ambitions
on aimerait le savoir et on va le savoir
si cette contre-offensive temps annoncé
depuis le mois de mai a finalement lieu
on ne sait pas effectivement je suis
tout à fait d'accord est ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est à dire que nous avons
un pays agresseur qui a lancé une
offensive c'est la russie et nous avons
un pays dans lequel se déroule tout tout
les toutes les actions et qui est en
train d'être détruit c'est l'ukraine et
l'ukraine donc est en position défensive
en position de résistance ça n'est pas
du tout la même chose que d'être en
position d'offensive il y a un problème
quand même d'armement les ukrainiens que
j'ai été voir sur place dans l'armée ou
wire et tous les journalistes qui ont
été sur place le dise ne pense qu'à une
chose et ne cesse de le répéter c'est
qu'on leur donne des armes surtout qu'on
ne cesse pas de les leur donner donc ils
ont eu récemment cet été quelques
victoires quand même très stratégique
grâce à l'armement les imac alors que
les occidentaux leur ont envoyé qui ont
permis de frapper plus loin qui ont
permis de préfet en crimée en crimée la
crimée cette péninsule qui a été reprise
en 2014 n'avait pas été touchée depuis
le mois de février dernier donc ça ça a
quand même choqué particulièrement
l'opinion publique en russie on a tous
vu ces images et ça c'est important mais
de là à être capable de reprendre cette
première ville renson qui a été très
facilement prise trop facilement prise
d'ailleurs le président est né ce qui
l'a dit lui même on se demande s'il n'ya
pas eu des actes de trahison à ce
moment-là ça c'était en février on ne
sait pas donc pour le moment on en est
là moi je trouve quand même que l'été a
passé et qu'on n'a pas il n'y a pas eu
de grandes avancées ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre on est plutôt pour le moment
dans un conflit relativement figée et
donc les prochains jours nous diront
quels sont les moyens mais c'est
toujours le terrain raphael qui fait la
différence on veut et moi j'ai beaucoup
de mal à vous en parler quand je ne suis
pas sur le terrain c'est lui même quand
on est sur le terrain c'est très
difficile puisque justement les gens sur
le terrain parfois se demande d'où
viennent les missiles s'ils viennent du
côté ukrainien s'ils viennent du côté
russe c'est ça la dispute autour de la
centrale de 2 à corriger aujourd'hui
autre crise cette fois ci ce n'est pas
encore la guerre mais une atmosphère
d'insurrection en irak après l annonce
du retrait défi est il de la vie
politique de moqtada sadr earl ses
partisans eux ont envahi le palais de la
république là où siège le conseil des
ministes vous connaissez bien miracle
vous vous êtes rendu de très nombreuses
fois on en a parlé il ya quelques
instants vous avez effectué nombreux
reportages sur place comment comprendre
d'après vous l'annnonce de moktada sadr
c'est une réelle exaspération face aux
blocages politiques ou bien voir la
recherche en fait d'un plébiscite c'est
très très étonnant 7 cette volte-face de
moqtada al-sadr moktada al sadr donc
effectivement moi vous avez dit j'étais
de nombreuses fois en irak pourquoi mais
j'ai été pour couvrir la guerre parce
qu'il faut pas oublier qu'en irak il ya
la guerre il ya depuis 2003 et
actuel c'est à dire on est écouté mois
toutes les guerres que j'ai couvertes y
en a pas une qui est réellement terminée
aujourd'hui un nid la tchétchénie ni
l'irak ni l'afghanistan bien ce qui se
passe en afghanistan ce qui se passe en
irak aujourd'hui et ce qui s'est passé
donc la décision de moqtada sadr hier ce
matin et de jeter l'épongé c'est quand
même assez étonnant c'est à dire il
laisse tomber sa airs il autorise le
chaos et c'est en fait justement son
expression de son ras-le-bol du fait qu'
il n'y a pas d'état il n'y a pas d'état
véritablement fort en irak depuis très
longtemps les américains n'ont donc pas
réussi à grand-chose en irak il n'y a
pas de budget de l'état depuis deux ans
moktada al sadr est ce qu'on peut le
croire il a toujours voulu il a jamais
véritablement réussi à être le leader
qu'il aurait peut-être mérité être il a
toujours eu ce genre de volte-face moi
j'ai du mal à croire que véritablement
il quitte la scène de façon définitive
est-ce que c'est pas plutôt une énième
volte face qui permettra c'est à dire
que comme il ne sait plus quoi faire au
niveau disons politique régulier il
laissait il laisse ses partisans faire
et ses partisans qu est ce qu ils ont
été faire aujourd'hui mais ils ont
réussi leur entrée dans la zone verte
comme vous l'avait dit et est en fait il
ya une menace de violence aujourd'hui
mais ça c'est pas nouveau pour l'irak
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'elle n'est pas
stable et tout cela entre milices
chiites entre mille ici à dix les
antilles en face de nos humanités
absolument puisque nouri al-maliki l'ex
premier ministre est la bête noire
détester
par moqtada al sadr mais tout ça est la
preuve que
les cheats n'arrive pas du tout à se
mettre d'accord en trop alors qu il y
arrivait jusqu'à il ya pas si longtemps
pour justement mettre au sommet de
l'état un premier ministre et un
président donc c'est une faillite totale
qui fait très peur
baptiste on va peut être résumée ou
rappelés en tout cas quels sont les
germes de la crise actuelle puisque
c'est le fruit d'un an de crise
gouvernement tous la dernière crise ça
date d'octobre dernier effectivement
avec ces élections législatives qui ont
finalement conforté la position
majoritaire du courant sadriste avec 73
députés au parlement il a tenté de nier
pour autant sa majorité absolue il a
tenté de négocier pour la formation d'un
gouvernement il n'y est paré arrivée il
a demandé à ses députés de démissionner
énième volte face justement vous les
vieux qui ait précédemment il assez
coutumier du fait et puis depuis voilà
ce blocage donc ils avaient ils avaient
lancé un ultimatum durant bien voilà il
avait lancé un ultimatum pour que tout
le monde démissionne toutefois la partie
des missions des différents par remettre
à zéro la liaison est de faire ça aux
enfers sous couvert de lutte anti
corruption
que faire maintenant que faire alors est
ce qu'il faut faire une énième
dissolution c'est à dire un geste
démocratique pour avoir des élections
sachant que le problème ils souhaitent
ils souhaitent de nouvelles élections
avant le gouvernement ses adversaires ne
sont pas contre de nouvelles élections
contraire mais ils veulent un
gouvernement d'abord voilà donc c'est
comment former ce gouvernement le
problème vous l'avez dit il est beaucoup
plus en glisse t il ya cette lutte
derrière derrière ces querelles
idéologiques il ya aussi cette lutte
d'hommes effectivement bien sûr à contre
nouri el maliki sa bête noire ils se
sont affrontés en 2008 à l'époque nouri
al maliki était premier ministre il y
avait eu lieu par les américains
soutenus par les américains et les
britanniques et ils avaient entre
guillemets écrasé l'armée du mahdi
mémoire finalement il y avait une
victoire politique quand même pour
moktada al sadr mais finalement les
rancoeurs sont menacés et ses rancoeurs
elle persiste aujourd'hui il ya aussi
également le rôle de l'iran avec moqtada
l'ambiguïté de l'octa d'al sadd envisage
navire et qu' un coût plus ou moins
écoutés rang de l'autre affiche son
indépendance voire son nationalisme donc
ce rôle dit on qu'on n'a pas réglé aussi
le problème crucial fondamentale qui est
le rôle l'ingérence de l'iran dans la
politique irakienne on n'arrivera pas à
grand chose donc voilà aujourd'hui en
plus on a des partisans de moqtada sadr
qui sont chauffés à blanc dans un pays
où on sait qu'il ya énormément d'armes
parmi la population ça laisse pas
vraiment dur et je suis de 10 positive
entre guéret long terme d'éviter
l'éclatement quand on vous écoute on
fait tout et qui détient les qu'on se
repose la question de l'éclatement de
l'irak depuis depuis cette guerre depuis
2003 puisque defacto il n'y avait pas
quand même là même genre de vie au
kurdistan au nord qui étaient épargnées
et dans le reste de l'irak les mémés
mais à l'époque le conflit annonçant la
question se posait entre effectivement
communautés kurdes chiites et sunnites
là on a des affrontements intras un
trashy on a des affrontements un trafic
bien sûr parce que et oms a donné en
2015 si on parle d'une date importante
en 2015 c'est important en irak il ya
une contestation justement gigantesque
du pouvoir et là moi je faisais partie
de ceux qui avaient une espèce
d'optimisme parce que les gens
descendent dans la rue et puis
finalement justement moktada al sadr qui
était également à la tête de cette
contestation a glissé vers autre chose
il a glissé vers cette espèce de
nationalistes de réformisme irakien de
cette obsession qui l'a de dire qu'il va
obtenir la réforme mais comme il n'y
arrive pas et qu'il n'y est pas arrivé
finalement de la façon violente avec
l'arménie mardi et qu' il n'y arrive
toujours pas politiquement et bien
aujourd'hui c'était le blocus et il est
l'impression qu'il s'accumule à cette
espèce de d'auto il se fait presque hara
kiri aujourd'hui en moi j'ai peine à
croire que moqtada al sadr à quitter
définitivement la scène politique
irakienne le risque pour les mois ou les
années à venir anne d'un irak
durablement ingouvernable mais il est
ingouvernable depuis c'est à dire je on
a tous la mémoire courte mais il faut
pas oublier que c'est le chaos en irak
depuis le début de la guerre et le début
de la guerre c'est directement dans la
foulée 11 septembre 2001 ensuite à
l'automne 2001 on à l'invasion
évidemment de l'afghanistan et ensuite à
partie 2003 en irak mais avec une armée
qui a réussi tout de même avec la ville
de dijon à reconquérir son territoire
face à ce qui a été un temps d'arrêt et
vous pensez que ce relatif en power oui
c'est très relatif je pense que là on
parle exclusivement des divisions entre
chiites mais on ne va pas oublier non
plus une autre grande division d'irak et
la division entre sunnites et chiites
et c'est pas parce qu'on n'en parle pas
qu'elles n'existent plus les suisses qui
ont été longtemps la minorité
gouvernante du temps du saint maron 2
saddam hussein
merci anne ça nous fonde une conclusion
merci à vous d'avoir été parmi nous en
nous on retrouve évidemment chacun sait
dans on va plus loin et
occasionnellement régulièrement à voir
évidemment avec baptiste talbot si elle
reste du temps et derrière la caméra
rédacteur en chef à france 24 restez
avec nous on se retrouve dans un peu
plus de trois minutes pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]
chaque semaine